مبعث الخلاف الرئيسي بين روسيا وتركيا هو
ما تعتبره انقره تقع سان روسيا في تنفيذ
اتفاق سوتشي عام 2019 الذي نصه على انسحاب
ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه من
الحدود السوريه التركيه بعمق 30 كلم
شرطه العسكريه الروسيه وحرس الحدود
السوريه تسهيلا انسحاب المقاتلين الاكراد
مع اسلحتهم من منطقه الحزام الامني جنوبيه
تركيا لكن ذلك لم يتحقق رغم ذلك تعرض
روسيا عزمنا ترك علشان عمليه بريه جديده
في الشمال السوري فقد قال مبعوث الرئيس
الروسي الى سوريا الكسندر لافانتيم ان مثل
هذه العمليات العسكريه لا تاتي بنتائج
وانما تشجع الارهاب لكن بين روسيا وتركيا
قبول متبادل للوسطات ففي حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا نجحت الوساطه التركيه مع الامم
المتحده في حل ازمه تصدير الحبوب التي
تهدد بازمه غذاء عالميه اما الولايات
المتحده فلا يغيب عن الاذهان ان مبادرتها
ومحادثاتها مع تركيا كانت وراء وقف التوسع
البري التركي في عمليه نبع السلام بين تل
ابيض وراس العين اواخر عام 2019 بعدما
كانت انقره تعتزم التوسع شرقا باتجاه
الحسكه والمالكيه وغربا نحو عين العرب
كوباني لكن انقره وواشنطن منذ ذلك الحين
تختلفان بشان الطرف الذي يتعين ان تكون له
السيطره على المنطقه الامنه في الشمال
السوري واذا ما كان ينبغي ان تخرج منها ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ام لا
وتنتقل تركيا الدعم الامريكيه والغربيه
عموما لما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
حيث قال الرئيس اردوغان ان تركيا ليست
مضره لتحمل رياء القوه الداعمه من خلال
تغيير اسماء التنظيمات لتبريد دعمها بين
تركيا والولايات المتحده علاقه التعاون
الع الوثيقه ضمن حلف شمال الاطلسي لكن
خلافات لا تخفى بشان التردد الامريكي في
بيع انقره طائرات قتاليه من طراز اف 16 ما
جعل تركيا تلوح باللجوء الى شراء طائرات
قتال روسيه